on Angela live Channel thank you thank
you very much indeed
um good evening
members and welcome we look a bit thin
on the ground today
um but I'm sure we'll come to that in um
thank you councilor stamp you wanted me
to start on time
well I was going to say you want to meet
start on time now y'all
right well okay well that that's the
class job so good evening and welcome
strategy and resources committee on
Thursday the 21st of September 2023 my
name is councilor Mark Durham and I'm
chairperson of this committee members we
are streaming this meeting live as well
as recording and by being present in
this meeting you're giving your consent
being recorded during each item please
put your hand up to indicate if you wish
to speak and I will then invite you at
the appropriate time
could ask members to avoid approaching
the top table assists could create
interference with cameras and live
stream please note that the live stream
YouTube live stream sound recording is
dependent on the correct use of the
microphones therefore can ask that when
invited to speak you'll remember to turn
on your microphone turn it off when
finished please reference a page or
paragraph number when referring to the
agenda papers keep your contributions
clear and concise as possible thank you
very much indeed uh item two apologies
for absence Tara
so thank you chairman I apologize to
received from cancer Brown and councilor
white Council Morgan is attending as a
substitute for councilman and we have
been advised that Council lay may be
arriving a little late due to having to
chair a meeting at the tank house yeah I
saw I saw his email thank you very much
indeed thank you chairman
and uh
next item on the agenda are minutes
I'm just going down here so um
is recommended that the minutes of the
meeting held on the 20th of July this
year found on pages or planes are
commencing five of your agenda are
approved as a true and accurate record
ISO move do I have a second please
everybody happy please indicate
pleasing okay thank you
Declarations of interest to disclose the
existence and nature of any disclosable
pecuniary interests other registerable
interests and non-registerable interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraph nine
and appendix B of the code of conduct
for members and members you also remind
you that you are required to disclose an
interest as soon as you become aware
should the need arise during the meeting
members any Declarations of interest at
this stage no thank you very much indeed
item five public participation I don't
believe there is any is that Tara
uh
okay thank you which neatly brings us
around to the first report
which is
where is my agenda gone
it is here
ah councilor driver
is here that's fine just in time we've
just done the official bits councilor
driver
um we've just done the Declarations of
Interest I don't know if you've got any
that you wish to add thank you very much
indeed you know the rest so item six is
delivery of section 106 capital projects
for the year 2425 this is found on pages
11 to 14.
and uh this is Mr Dodson you're taking
us through this evening
Mr Howard why I'm sorry Mr Howard white
please go ahead thank you chair and good
evening good evening members
um this report concerns the council
section 106 capital projects for 2024-25
um and the before report provides an
update on the current position of those
contributions and seeks approval to
recruit a new fixed term resource using
Surplus Capital funding and therefore no
additional strain on the mtfs to deliver
our section 106 program of works
which as members be aware the council
receives a 106 contributions a part of
the planning approval process for large
applications
these Financial contributions are part
of the agreements between the council
and the developer and set up what those
contributions can be used for
chair this report only covers section
106 Financial Obligations that are due
to Modern District Council money shooter
ECC or the NHS are not included in this
report
chairman the council currently holds
contributions of approximately one
million pounds of section 106
contributions as such this represents a
fantastic opportunity to bring forward
some exciting new projects for the
benefits of the community
the table within report sets out those
contributions held by the council and
potential projects that could be
delivered subject to community
engagement
the council recognize that these
projects are of vital importance to the
community and therefore monitors the
position of these Financial
contributions to ensure they can be
delivered in a timely and effective way
chair recent service planning and
monitoring has demonstrated that these
projects are at risk of not being
delivered
the reason for this is the potential
risk is that no additional resources
were identified to deliver the work at
the time the allocations were made
in addition to existing staff are
already fully engaged on delivering the
council's own corporate Capital program
and repair and renewal programmer works
and don't have spare capacity to deliver
a program of this capacity of this scale
accounts has been proactive in reviewing
options to secure additional resource to
deliver the section 106 Capital program
as laid out in the report the council
has recently received confirmation from
the South Essex parking partnership or
set that will receive 137 000 pounds to
deliver capital projects within its car
Parks as part of that Surplus
the council had already identified the
capital assume to deliver these projects
from existing budgets
therefore as a result the set Surplus
funding now has a surplus on its own
capital budget of 137 000 pounds
so it's therefore proposed this Surplus
funding be used to fund a new fixed term
project manager to deliver the section
106 program of works
the charts Institute of Public Finance
and accountancy or sip for
have confirmed this guidance and they
confirmed the capital funding of this
type can be used to fund staff costs
incurred as a result of Staff spending
time on capital projects this can be
capitalized provided that time can be
linked to bring a specific asset into
working condition or substantially
enhancing the life of the asset
in conclusion the council has an
ambition program of section 106 funded
works and wishes to deliver these to
support its corporate priorities
the council has identified that these
projects are at risk of not being
delivered due to offers being fully
engaged or other corporate priorities
The Proposal set out in the report would
fund a new fixed term project manager to
deliver the section 106 program of Works
to devalue it of approximately one
million pounds at no direct additional
cost to the council above that already
set out in the medium-term financial
strategy
so that concludes a summary of the
report my colleague Sue Greene and Anne
altof Shoreland join us remotely and we
please take any questions members may
have thank you
thank you very much in indeed so members
you have um three recommendations uh for
this evening
um which I won't go through at this
moment but can I have um
any comments or questions please
councilor driver was first then
councilor Morgan
uh thank you chair it's just an
observation that these are not new
projects are they these are projects
that had been identified at the time
that the ldp was put together uh with
Associated uh proposed funding for for
these which we haven't yet managed to
deliver is that correct
yeah that's correct these are historical
projects someone going back a number of
years
councilor Morgan
oh yeah thank you chair um with regards
to the money due from the south ethics
parking partnership
um I happen to know because I'm on the
on it that
um that has to be actually approved by
the sep committee before this funds
released has that approval been received
chairman it has my colleague Sue green
who also has been heavily involved in
the set partnership as well as remotely
um minus saying it certainly has been
received and it's in our accounts I'll
just ask this Miss green could uh just
confirm please chair this is great yes
can you uh fill us in please thank you
chairman yes the the full service has
been agreed
and my understanding yes
yesterday evening so that that's episode
plus
um is is with the council
okay
I was waiting for you to indicate
councilor stamp go ahead uh thank you
chairman
um can I have reassurance that these
projects will be delivered in a timely
fashion and within the budget
um no disrespect but we all know
projects slip and I wouldn't want
anybody to come in back to this Council
asking for another six months funding to
deliver projects
um when it really should have been
costed in originally thank you
to Howard Wright
thank you chair um thank you for the
question it's it's an ambitious timeline
we've set ourselves but the planning
we've done today does identify that 18
months is sufficient to deliver the
programmer Works within the report
of course you can okay
um and can I have the reassurance that
the members will be um included not just
the specific Ward members but the
members of Burnham on Crouch which this
four of us
um even though it's they're going to be
delivered in the South Ward not the
northward which is mind chair and also I
am concerned about the level of
consultation again
um because a lot of work was done
originally so if there's anything
present members can do and even past
members can do because I know councilor
schemes was heavily involved especially
with delivery of the BMX park it might
be an idea he's now a town councilor and
he may be able to help support so the
delivery could be quicker by doing that
and saving some money in some time to
deliver the project rather than risk
running out of funding chairman if
that's okay
thank you chair uh thank you Council
stamp um yes we would certainly be
reaching out to to members uh Ward
members and wider members to engage and
consult on the type of programs our
projects to deliver and
um in terms of reporting back to members
recommendations three yeah recognition
three uh would be a quarterly report to
this committee on updates of the program
so happy to bring that forward
yeah there's a there's a point I want to
raise and counselor a stamp will be
aware as well
um because we both sat on the ysgs until
they were disbanded and there was
discussion about using ysg funding
particularly for the
skate park and in fact the design of
that was progressed in association with
the youngsters themselves wasn't it and
there was a there was a design I believe
agreed so what I don't want to do is to
be rewriting that book from the start
when a lot of the preliminary work was
done and also I'd like to know what's
happened to the to the the funding that
was given to the ysg for those projects
thank you chair I can't comment on that
particular funding question but I can
comment on engagement with the ysg if
that's helpful we've met with them a
number of weeks back
um to review the work they've done
previously the their Outreach work their
engagement with young people and some
other designs who also had um for the
skate park so certainly we can bring
that forward uh we're not starting from
a standing start we have some
information we can use already so uh
contact's been made and it's certainly
helpful to get that part of project
moving yeah I I think because in our ysg
meetings it there was they made the
point very strongly that it's not for us
old Focus to be designing skate parks
there are you know their their
requirements
you know the people that we should be uh
people we should be Consulting with
other people that use them because they
know what they want so I'm pleased that
that is not going to be
um not going to be wasted
councilor siddle
thank you chair
just wanted to check uh when
these amounts were defined because if it
was a couple of years ago obviously
we've had a lot of inflation in terms of
so are are these figures as as of now
because we know with inflation and we
know for example with the Pontoon in
Burnham the cost of that has gone up uh
so yeah are we sure that you know this
has got the right amount of contingency
in and that we will be able to use the
the budget in the right way
thank you chair
um I'm very conscious of the inflation
Point um I think along with this project
um stalls until we get off the ground we
are uh we're losing value of that money
I am really conscious to move this
forward hence to bring a report for you
this evening I'm very very mindful of
that in terms of whether these are hard
figures or inflation links I will bring
in uh Anne if I may to just to confirm
that point and works on our planning
team I'll be able to answer that
question for us
yes good evening
hello
um the section 106 funding is indexed so
we do we add indexation onto the
invoices that we send out to developers
so the negotiate the initial negotiated
amount
is always less than the money than they
they actually pay
right okay so we just got to hope that
whatever index you're increasing it by
is equivalent to the inflation in
construction costs which I tend to doubt
but um okay
yeah we use the um industry
specifications on um it's the
acis website and it calculates it for us
okay thank you councilor fitek um yeah I
just want to point out they're only
indexed up to the point of receipt so if
they've been received three years ago or
two years ago or one years ago then they
won't be in text with a
that's correct yeah that is correct so
we get to invoice for these is that
correct
yes okay yeah
[Music]
we work out the index station and then
we invoice the developer and then they
pay us
okay now there will become a stage where
if we don't utilize These funds then
they could be repayable
um and and where are we with that please
we have plenty of time actually I think
the first one is due in October 26th to
be paid back right okay thank you
councilor are you okay councilor fitted
yeah councilor stamp and I asked the
thick question no such thing as a silly
off that question please back of cancer
it's what cancer students just raised so
have we got the money is it fixed is it
gonna go up before the before the
Project's been delivered Asylum wants to
know yeah we haven't got we haven't got
the money yet they haven't been invoiced
I haven't invoiced it so that we haven't
advice for it so it could be more than
this that's what we just heard yes this
is a Baseline and there would this is
will be indexed at to the point of
invoice and wants to come back here yeah
please come back yeah all the money's in
the bag
all right
2B which has not been factored into this
uh these calculations anyway
so therefore we will be subject to in at
risk of of our value not being
sufficient or what it was when we
received the money
yes
yeah okay
Mr Harwood white when was it paid I I
think it's If We Hold up money now we
are subject to inflationary pressure now
um so right
um as an set out hence the the need to
to move the project forward as quickly
as possible yeah while its value remains
what it is and the councilor driver
yeah thank you chair can I just ask
about
um what or how the set money could have
been used if we don't use it for this
purpose I'm suggesting we don't use it
for this purpose because it seems like
it's a useful thing but how else might
it have been used
yeah thank you Mrs Green yeah
and so the um the funding that we had
from sep um has actually been fully
committed against various projects
two of two of the projects
um were projects that the council had
already got in its capital plan
therefore part of the service we
received was to find new projects and
part of it was to fund existing projects
so what that has an effect on is it's
enabled us to talk some of the capital
back into our own accounts who would be
able to use that in any way that the
council considers as a priority so at
the moment there are no restrictions on
the use of that part of the it actually
doesn't accept funding it's the it's the
council's capital but it's been made
available through the receipt of asset
funding which is now being used yeah to
fund projects that otherwise we would
have funded ourselves as I recall it
there was discussion
a while ago when the set money was
wasn't offered but it was it well it was
if in effect offered
we used it instead of our capital budget
for I think we refurbished some car
parts didn't we and did some work there
because broadly broadly it had to it had
to be parking linked so what we're
actually committing now is what was from
our capital budget that we didn't have
to spend because we got the set money is
that that's broadly correct isn't it
that's correct okay right councilor
driver
uh to be slightly controversial then
potentially there would be money for
instance to introduce parking in Burnham
and get an income from it so I'm not
saying you know we we should use it in
that way but it's it is a it's an
opportunity cost isn't it we have chosen
not to use it along those lines uh uh to
enable these these projects which I
accept it seems a sensible Way Forward
but there is an opportunity cost
associated with not using it potentially
for car Parks I think it's it's other
areas in the Dengue thank you it was an
unexpected bonus that came through
because of the Surplus generated by the
South Essex parking partnership and it
it their Surplus was divided up between
all of the members of there because
previously Southeast parking partnership
had made quite significant deficits and
authorities had to chip in basically to
balance the books so they've cleared and
accumulated
um Surplus by redistributing amongst its
members councilor Morgan
yeah yesterday just to sort of clarify
that the money produced from sep has to
be used specifically for parking
purposes and MDC would help well how
it's gone back has to go back to SEP
with its plans of how that money is to
be spent and set then approves it and
gives the money so there isn't really
anything else available from that
particular funds all that's happened is
that we've been able to release
buildings on my capital budget because
of those possible Right members we've
heard from officers uh councilor Fluker
10 minutes at one o'clock this afternoon
I didn't know anything about skate parks
but now I feel as I could take it as a
specialist subject in Mastermind
um I'm interested in a lot of things in
this report
um I mean there's an awful lot of risks
around appointing somebody into this
role I mean you know we're talking about
an 18-month appointment
um officers and some of the longer
serving members will remember what
happened for example when we had an
outside contractor coming to review the
planning department so I won't dwell on
that
um it seems to me that if we're going to
build anything reasonable then we are
going to need plan information
um I spoke to Paz today and they said
that is quite possible if we were to
build a reasonable scheme I mean that
could take four months to sort out
so you know if we if we appoint somebody
into this role four months on the
figures that are in this report and that
would be 28 000 quid and and chairman
you have to I I mean I'm sure that
Mr uh Harwood white uh has already had
long conversations with skateboard GB
I was looking for a signal I didn't get
one but chairman that's the key to this
skateboard GP uh uh actually lies you
know it it's a design and development
guidance for skateboards and they say
it's absolutely important that you
consult with exactly the people you
mention now the whole of the skateboard
sport has changed dramatically in the
last six months 12 months 18 months we
will almost certainly have to go out to
consultation again it would be the only
right and proper thing to do
um they are saying a minimum of three
months consultation the cost of that
chairman paying somebody for that period
of time would be 21 000. tell me if I've
got it right there's 814 000 pounds uh
aligned to the provision of renovation
Escape of the skate parks and the
provision of new ones
um
again I'm I'm sure that
um the officers spoken to the likes of
Maverick and Clark and Kent who I've
been in touch with and they provide
TurnKey solutions for this type of work
so what they would do
um what they would do they would come up
with the design building delivery
project management that is actually what
was happening under the youth service so
and chairman they would also handle the
public consultation come up with a
design
suitable for skates German scoots bikes
and wmx and we should not forget about
the wmx really really important and I'm
sure for your time on the ysg you'll
know exactly what that is and and
chairman they come up with detail
costings and fixed price contract and
I'd also refer officers to Gloucester uh
they've got a fantastic piece of
fantastic document on their website it's
a little old but it does actually say so
and and something chairman which I'm
staggered that this report doesn't speak
to and that's ongoing costs
um loss uh Royal Society prevention of
accidents
um they actually say and you can pick
this information up from skateboard GB
um that depending whether you go on a
steel scheme or Timber scheme or
concrete the annual costs to maintain
them is around about 10 a minimum of 10
so I'd like to know if anybody has
spoken to these companies because if
they do they'll they'll see the The
Marvelous things that have been
delivered throughout the country and uh
and who knows chairman we might go and
visit the New Haven pump track because
that is supposed to be one of the best
local Authority tracks in the country
um
my view on this is is that chairman if
we were I think the Chairman's senior
Council
um my view on this chairman is we should
explore this because if they bring
forward a design and delivery package
deal with the consultation then we don't
need anybody in-house certainly not to
the tune of 85
000 pounds per annum this could be moved
to one of these companies I've spoken to
them this is exactly what they do for
other local authorities I think we're a
little bit tied up here whereas on one
hand we are saying that we you know we
need to get this sorted out and we need
an officer to deal with this but to me
there's a simple solution to this which
would actually mean more money going
into these projects and I'm sure there
will be more money going into them Chen
because I'm sure that the section 151
officer will agree with me that if we've
had 814 000 pounds on deposit uh then
perhaps that's a that's attracted some
kind of in investment income and that
should be added on to this so chairman
um
and before I'd go on to making a
proposal
um
in the report uh paragraph 3.7.5
um it says basically
um that this officer will also uh
support the delivery of other projects
well I can imagine where we'd be in 18
months time we'll what will happen is
we'll say oh this officer's been
involved in everything else and that's
why it's not delivered on Escape Park in
Riverside Park or Promenade Park if if
we are to agree to this role it should
be totally and utterly focused on
delivering those projects Jim I'll just
speak briefly to the sensory play areas
because I think it would be wrong not to
briefly yeah yeah yeah I'm there
um
again I believe I believe in that
private meeting uh on the day before
yesterday that I attended I think
somebody spoke about the sensory
um thing and you might like to ask the
question chairman you know what the the
intelligence is around that because my
understanding is they haven't found
anybody to deliver that chairman I think
sensory play areas are very very
important but again you know we should
be thinking outside the box we should be
more proactive than reactive and I would
have thought tying up with the rhs or
little College who actually uh have
courses on these I think they'd probably
love to have an area to come and build
one so maybe we should do that my
proposal is is that uh we either defer
until we've got more information or
chairman we don't appoint this person we
don't take uh whatever it is 135 000
pounds a year uh out of our funds to pay
for this post and that we explore the
opportunity chairman of uh going to a
design and build company who by the way
chairman would happily look at this as a
whole project so they would deal with
refurbishment and they would deal with
the provision of new they would deal
with that all in-house and they
potentially could save this Council a
lot of money thank you chairman I've
made my proposal well I'm going to yes
I'm aware that that is the route that
the youth service were progressing and I
can't remember the name of the
contractor and I'm sure councilor stamp
can't either but that was a design and
build consultancy looking at the the
design and of course it's a replacement
of an existing so probably wouldn't need
planning in respect of the prawn Park
um so I mean I'm sure that that can be
answered
um
let's yes let's let's um let myself Mr
um Howard white answer your questions
thank you chair
um in terms of Engagement
um with with communities it's mentioned
the report and these are the projects
mentioned within the report
foreign
and does give us some flexibility in
terms of what could be delivered at each
of those sites within the terms of the
section 106 agreement
um so that would be as a result of
community engagement so the officer
speaking with the community with members
with the ysg and others around what the
facility could look like what type of
facility could be brought forward
within the terms of of the agreement
in terms of
um 3.7.5 Council fluke conventions
um supporting other capital projects
what the thought sets out this project
manager would be their priority and
their focus would be the section 106
program the seta and the reports
whether if there was capacity and time
where possible they could support other
Capital programs the council was
delivering last year we didn't fully
deliver our Capital program due to other
capacity issues so if there was capacity
within that role they could support our
own Capital program and add some more
resource for that team but the priority
and their focus would be on the section
106 programmer Works dedicated lows
projects within in the report chairman
I'm going to ask the question which I
think was where councilor fluke was
eluding
the question is have we looked we've got
a million pounds to spend
have we looked at taking that million
pounds to a design and build company for
a turnkey solution
for all of these items because there are
companies out there um
I I have I have
experienced okay I'll declare an
interest in that I'm a Cabinet member
for Country Parks we have a BMX track on
Hadley Country Park which was built
funded largely by sport England
built for the Olympic Games in 2012 it
is a maintenance Nightmare and it is
costing an absolute
fortune and we cannot get out of that
maintenance liability because of the
contract with sport England and what it
created was a BMX track for Olympics
quality bikers which is more or less
lethal for anybody else going there so
you know a quarter of it is
unusable so you know I we do have to
take the ongoing Revenue costs out as
asset
um as a consideration but um Mr Howard
white have you got in terms of Revenue
implications Jay you're quite right
anything with Bill will have a revenue
um pressure
um of what I've seen my time Malden we
uh there are pressures on those assets
uh there always are any asset you build
will have a revenue pressure we'll need
to consider that with anything we bring
forward
um equally if we are uh replacing uh
facilities and assets uh we could
actually reduce some of our maintenance
liabilities where these assets are aging
but certainly if it's a new asset that
we're adding to the um
talk to our portfolio yes it would have
Revenue stream we have to carefully
consider that in terms of construction
materials life of the asset anything
else you'd expect here so there would be
potentially revenue streams on some new
assets but also savings on anything we
replaced as new
um over the health channel so my my
question have we considered going out to
a company and saying here's a million
pounds come up with these products
in short notion we haven't our
preference is to have a project manager
within the team that knows our processes
our area our priorities that could work
with our local people and local members
um to bring those schemes forward
if we went to design a builder still
need to be a level of Team involvement
to work with them to engage to consult
to bring that forward and we don't feel
within the team the countries we have we
could deliver that effectively hence our
recommendation share to have a
fixed-time project manager within that
Surplus although that work had started
with the youth service honestly I'm okay
I'm going to go to councilor oh
councilor fluge come back of course you
can so it's much yeah okay well yeah I'm
grateful for that but I've sort of
drilled in a bit of this consultation
there's absolutely nothing about wcmx
and that's the key to getting some more
funding I'm I'm sure that Mr Howard
white knows exactly what I'm talking
about uh it's absolutely critical that
we do do these consultations
eternally key solution provider will
handle it all you know they will
probably come up with a slit they'll do
your consultation they'll come back here
they'll do a presentation and it's job
done and they will come up with a figure
uh which we can then present to the the
106 funder and and we don't have all
this complications about finding 145
Grand and and chairman the the impact on
resources Financial
um I understand what Mr White says about
all projects do have on costs but it
should be mentioned in there chairman I
think that you know members should be
reminded that if we deliver these
projects potentially if you were to
believe what rusper said we could be
talking about 80 000 pounds a year in
maintenance fees
and what that should be in this report
I'm not saying that that should stop us
doing it but members should be reminded
of these things thank you chairman yeah
and of course the existing state skate
park has needed funding every year so
I'm going to go to councilor siddle
first and councilor Thompson then
councilor fitter
uh thank you chair uh the site at Hadley
Park is a is a mountain bike site which
is a completely different situation to a
BMX track so they are two completely
different things I can appreciate what
what cancer Sudoku is saying however as
Mr Harvard white has pointed out and as
officers have pointed out we do not have
the internal resources to deliver these
projects that's why that's why they
haven't been delivered because we don't
have the internal resources that's why
it's not happened it's not happened over
the last four years councilor fluka so
you need to we need to be aware of that
and the whole point of this position is
having a project manager who will go out
to these organizations consult with
those organizations and use them
sorry did I say anything while you were
talking councilor fluka no I wasn't
talking about
memberspirated because that's exactly
how you're going to counselves so you
chairman you're going to stretch this
project you know at the end of the day
chairman I could I could lead the
council tomorrow and chairman I will
come and do this please
when me in the conversation okay
slipping and puffing can we not
counselor siddle let's get on with the
business so the business is we need this
resource to be able to deliver the
projects and it's not just BMX projects
it's other projects as well without this
resource and because of the
transformation we don't have enough
resources in this Authority so we are
having to employ additional resources so
the section 106 money can be spent it
hasn't been spent in the last four years
when the conservatives were in the
majority running this Administration
councilor fluka so we need to ensure
that we deliver this so that we are able
to deliver the section 106 money without
the project manager we do not have the
internal resource to deliver it that
internal resource I'm sure will do more
than Council Fluker has done today by
going on Google and talking to few
organizations
well firstly councilor siddle this is
not this is not the venue for bringing
political statements in and I think that
was uncalled for and unnecessary and I
think you should also take account of
the fact that in the out of the last
four years we've had two years of haters
due to the covid and it you know I wish
it was as simple as you've just pointed
out but I'm afraid it wasn't but your
point is taken counselor Thompson
oh thank you chairman
um
yeah I
there's some good suggestions here but
they can't be done like that in
isolation as Mr Harwood whites already
said you know there needs to be liaison
with this Authority and someone's got to
do it and I it doesn't seem we have the
resource to do that I do have one
question what what other projects are
there that aren't youth projects that
need to be covered by this section 106
officer and what sort of value are we
talking about
thank you chair thank you councilor um
if you're referring to the other
council's Capital programs and RR
programs
um let's see the other section 1061
sorry chairman this is the totality of
our section 106.
um money beholds yes right just
um
yeah on that basis I think we probably
should defer and give the officers time
to see if there's another way maybe we
don't need this officer for so long or
you know maybe you need to think about
exactly what time they would need what
point they'd need to start but that's
for this this without some extra
resource it seems to me
where are we going to get it from well
well maybe it is but it wasn't actually
intended to be I'm
okay let's wait until we've heard from
everybody shall we counselor Thompson
councilor fitter so let's see what uh
thank you chairman um just for purposes
of clarity if what we're saying that
this 137 pound is in the capital count
and it's become available because there
are capital projects approved that then
got replaced by the separate money then
in principle this money came from the
general reserves and could be put back
into the general Reserve there's no
capital projects for it so I think it's
important that we understand what money
we're spending and why
um and I do think what councilor Lucas
says is is valid to some degree but on
the other hand
um residence I speak to don't see
there's been much benefit from order
development over the last 10 years and
doing these things in a relatively quick
time frame would be of tremendous
benefit I think to the morale of the
residents but it's a question of whether
the Council of fluger's proposal would
be the right way forward or whether the
officers um recommendation for project
management
I I think it's a difficult one and
perhaps there is no need for a bit more
time to consider this matter I I stand
to be corrected but as I understand it
if we don't use the one because bear in
mind the 106 money
is given the approval stage and is for a
specific purpose if we don't use it for
that we have to return it to the
developer so putting it back into the
general fund is not not an option well
we've got five figures
Miss Lucas
um I just wanted to clarify in terms of
the the funding that's been replaced
from the
Capital program
um yeah so those those funds are
allocated for um from now capital
reserve so they do need to be spent and
they do need to be capitalizable so if
it wasn't used for this purpose then
they would need to be recycled back into
the capital program in some form and
they couldn't just be returned to
General balances but in terms of the
actual Port that this this money is
intended to deliver you're right that
you know the
um they're limited to the section 106
agreements that were originally agreed
with the developers so that there's the
actual deliverable part if you like
which is
um for the purposes of section 106 and
this money that's been released from the
capital program needs to be spent um on
capsule projects or the delivery of
capital projects so we have to spend
this amount on those facilities because
that's what was in the section 106
agreement
yes Azan said the the monies in the
section 106 are are set out for
particular purposes and have to be used
for those purposes the the the money
that's been
um
is proposed to be allocated from the um
Capital program has come from Capital
reserves and therefore could either be
returned to the cap the council's
capital program and useful alternative
capital projects
um but it couldn't just be returned into
the general balance and use of Revenue
purpose okay thank you thank you very
much did you want to answer me Mr Howard
white on no Jim I'll just agree with uh
you know Lucas in terms of that position
that's entirely correct
councilor Thompson yeah go ahead yeah
sorry could have come back briefly
please chairman I mean
yeah the projects need to be done in
time and the residents want them they
don't want to wait forever for them my
only concern is that we do get maximum
value from this money and we have the
officer you know obviously the right
Officer but also for the right length of
time and doing the right work so that
the residents get maximum value which is
what the idea is
um I I don't know if officers need more
time to
the only thing I would say is that that
is the role of a project manager to make
sure that we get best value from the
project
so you know it you can argue it both
ways can't you so you know what I don't
think we can do
is just to keep kicking this down the
road we do make need to make make a
decision because as we've heard us every
week that goes by the finished product
is going to vary
due to the inflation
so I'm what I'm going to do is put the
recommendations as per the agenda and
we'll see where we get it yes kept Mr
Harwood White
sorry Chad just before you do that chair
just to if it helps chair and members to
clarify
um in terms of
we've spoken about designer build option
that's been been discussed just to
clarify my earlier response
if you were to go down that road that
will still require some level of project
management resource I appreciate that I
think it's it's worth just reflecting on
um previously the council as other
members have stated hasn't delivered on
the section 106 program but equally
we've actually haven't fully delivered
our own corporate Capital program either
for our internal resource um so it's
worth clarifying that
in terms of the position the council was
in we're not actually delivering our own
program let alone this new one-minute
pound program
um just to put down to context chairman
in terms of project management in
addition to any designer build we would
have for the 106 program thank you
counselors Luke you put the challenge
out I think and no Channel I've really I
just wanted to remind you and I'm sure
as soon as I start you'll remember but
you never actually put your um the
recommendations no I didn't but yours
wasn't seconded to my knowledge I
believe mine was seconded I didn't
notice anybody well I seconded uh
counselor uh what's it but Gemini
there's nothing to stop
sorry that I was in a different place
then yeah so counselor Thompson chairman
I'm grateful Council of Luca didn't
refer to me as capital Cruella but so
that was Morris can we I actually don't
believe I did I didn't second it I was
going over something
I definitely
um councilor Thompson made a proposal
chairman but for clarity and bear in
mind you still haven't made your
recommendation I would propose Gem and
that we we defer this to allow Mr
Harvard white to speak to skateboard GB
to speak to Maverick Clark and Kent and
come up with with an alternative to
spending uh a hundred and forty thousand
pounds okay Council folks so that's a
legitimate proposal so now we want a
second for that
well thank you very much right so I will
therefore put
right
well you didn't have two councilor
Thompson because I was going to put the
substantive
recommendation but
counselor no I'm not come on members you
know how this works please let's just
have a little
you know sorry this is for the residents
and the residents deserve better than
what they're getting I'm afraid cancel
uh so if we were to vote in favor of
councilor feluca's recommendation I'd
like to hear from Mr Harvard white what
the implications are for the uh existing
staff and existing projects and what
projects will be delayed as a result of
that and what pressure that will put on
our existing staff members in terms of
going out to that consultation and not
having a project manager to do it
uh Mr Harwood White You by all means
answer if you can thank you chairman it
it is difficult to quantify at this
point in terms of exactly what would be
delayed I am conscious
um
the council's capital program includes
items such as replacing the Galleon On
Prom Park and other projects and other
improvements in our car parks and other
assets
um I'd have to speak to colleagues about
reprioritizing uh what that would look
like and The Wider service plan
um but as I said previously we haven't
further our own Capital program last
year and I'm concerned we would fall
further behind chairman
works right I'll let counselor stamp
it's a quick one really chairman so
basically let's be honest about it if we
do agree with the office's
recommendation we're supporting the
other projects on this Council to be
delivered so so it needs it really
doesn't it should have been more clear I
think that we are actually using section
10 we are actually using the under 37 to
subsidize and help deliver the projects
what which should have been delivered
and we haven't So based on that I
totally do really agree with councilor
Lucas in principle but I'm certainly
don't want to be the reason why our
capital projects are not being delivered
but I do want the assurance that the
section 106 money and the projects will
be delivered because if mark my words if
they are not in the time frame and you
come back for the money from the council
this decision and this meeting will come
to haunt you but it will because we need
the guarantees counselor fluency
they will do their utmost to deliver but
yes Mr Harvard white it's through you
through you chair
um thank you councilor stamp
um
yeah of course before us we have a
million pounds worth of investment in
the community all I've read is I'm sure
and members will gather behind that fact
and how we need to bring that forward
I'm sure residents will really gladly
welcome that and I'm really want to move
that forward hence the um program
tonight given the scale of that program
and bear in mind it's roughly double the
own council's corporate program it's
significant in terms of what we're
looking to deliver I've already said we
were behind on our Capital program last
year and the year before there are
challenges there are dependencies and
all those programs in any Capital
program an aging estate I can't sit here
and guarantee in 18 months that'll be
living as full what we can do is bring
forward a project manager to manage the
process the dependencies within that
project to bring forward the projects
within that report that's what I'm
striving to do that sort of report sets
out to do hope that's helpful but in
terms of what we're looking to achieve
that's the ambition and so that's what
that program manager would be there
dedicated to doing bringing forward a
million pounds worth of section 106
investment for this SAP with this
Council for a number of years chairman
as well put thank you right councilor
Thompson final goal thank you chairman I
appreciate I've had a couple of girls
but not on this particular proposal I
mean give given that obviously there
needs to be some resource even with the
turnkey solution and given that a
professional project manager might well
be looking at a turnkey solution thus
freeing up some time to work on all
these other capital projects I mean if
our residents are going to get really
good value for money out of this project
manager and using a turnkey solution
simply well simply means that residents
get more of our capital projects
provided that's fine just because I said
that it doesn't mean I'm actually going
to vote for it I'm just want to get it
all discussed and out there so that we
can do the right thing so are you are
you still seconding counselor fluka's
proposal
whether I take I take that as a yes
counselor driver thank you chair
um I I think I said that the the at the
full Council last week about my concerns
about us not actually delivering
infrastructure and that out there there
is a huge concern that housing are going
is going up without the promised
infrastructure and we have an
opportunity here to try and get some of
that infrastructure in place
so our residents start to see some
benefit from all the housing going up
which they're not seeing at the moment I
do have some sympathy with councilor
fluka's concern about a turnkey solution
and uh and the fact that that's not on
the table however I recognize the wider
point that it is the delivery of uh of
this s-106 money and also its benefit to
delivering some wider projects which we
haven't been able to do as yet which
hopefully residents will see a benefit
too so
driver probably refers to is education
and Healthcare which is not actually in
the remit of this and indeed highways no
I'm not I'm talking about I mean across
the piece across the peace
infrastructure thank you right councilor
fluka you made a proposal it was
seconded by Council Thompson in as few
words as you can possibly manage it
could you summarize what your proposal
is please thank you chairman but I'm
sure the clerk's recorded it well that I
my proposal
um was the chairman that we we deferred
this decision for four weeks uh in order
for Mr Harvard white to ask answer some
of these questions that I've proposed so
that we can either get either we can go
down the turnkey solution or not German
this is a huge okay money and and
chairman I I won't ask for a recorded
vote but I'd like my vote recorded thing
I think we yes uh Mr did you get that
and are you happy to second that version
councilor Thompson
having got this far chairman yes I think
I'd rather not benefit all that
half an hour wasted Miss bird can we
are you happy with that
I think so right okay so that please
indicate members those in favor of
councilor flukers
uh proposal
it's more than four weeks it's six weeks
it was fairly straightforward
councilor's stamp it was to to defer
pending other Solutions including a
turnkey
right so please indicate those in favor
of councilor fluka's proposal
thank you right okay so there are two
and those are three
and those against
one one two three four
so uh that is not carried councilor flag
would then for put the substantive
that and I'm going to take all three at
the same time so recommendations under
item or point two
uh and that's little one two and three
those in favor of the recommendations in
the report please indicate
one one two three four five six those
against
thank you very much so that is
yes counselor siddle uh I would just
like to uh withdraw some of my comments
that I made about my conservative
colleagues and I apologize for any
offense that was called uh and I was not
in the right frame of mind when I made
this I don't think that was sincere your
apology is accepted gratefully thank you
thank you leader
um
yeah just to reiterate this is not about
political Point scoring this is about
delivering for residents
irrespective of the color of your
rosette right next item on the agenda
um
supplementary estimates environments
procurement exemptions use of reserves
quarter one and that will be Miss Lucas
I think
okay
Mr Fortress
thank you chair
good evening members
uh this is the quarterly report that
discloses the movements and budgets
reserves and procurement exemptions over
the three-month period to 30th of June
2023 for members noting an agreement as
per the rules and regulations set out in
section 3.1
this report asks members to note the
five environments it's detailed and
paragraph 3.3.1
to note the three procurement exemptions
detailed in paragraph
3.5.1 and to approve the one drawdown
from reserves described in paragraph
3.6.1
thank you chair
thank you very much indeed councilor
settle
uh thank you chair I have I have a
concern just just to get a bit more
information about things like grass
cutting
um and The Verge cutting it when yeah I
first joined the authority and one of
the things that we we did in terms of
what we were looking at in terms of the
authority was that we would look at
using uh
to make money and to sell our services
now it seems that those Services don't
seem to be able to cope with with what
we're doing we're having to go out and
spend money on additional
contractors to deliver those things uh
yeah I just want to know what the reason
behind that is and especially with the
cemetery because the cemetery I've had
quite a few things in in terms of my
mailbox about the cemetery yeah in terms
of that symmetry is that a one-off thing
is that an ongoing thing are we going to
be spending this money over the over the
next year so just yeah
to be clear about why is that we're
having to use contractors now
um and what the reasons are behind those
that that expenditure Fair comments I
don't know who can answer that
chairman I'm happy to uh yeah thank you
for that answer thank you uh chair thank
you Council um
well I join the authority back in
January one of the first things I did
was review the cemetery and Park Service
it came very clear to me very early
stages that there were severe pressures
across both teams
um
we were receiving a unacceptable number
of complaints across our Cemetery
service our cross-cutting service
Services well below where I want it to
be
um and I'm working I have been working
with the teams to review both servers to
see how we can deliver that better
um there's an interim measure we did
have some some vacancies so we've
managed to use that salary saving
um to bring in some some agency support
some ad hoc support to to get the
cemeteries back to where they need to be
in terms of a grants maintenance
provision
um certainly not a long-term provision
it literally got us over our initial
issue over the summer
but a service view process is ongoing to
look at various options to how we can
deal with this in the longer term it's
an issue from my understanding that the
teams I've had for a number of years now
uh and they've been firing funds using
salary savings to enable them to to
carry out that work that's not
sustainable in the long term uh it's not
value for money it doesn't meet our
recruitment regulations it means do
better in simple terms I'm working with
a team to bring forward a service review
and I hope to bring that to this
committee the next few months Jim
yeah again I mean I go back
before most people were here except
councilor fullgram councilor Thompson
there was a time when we were
effectively a contractor offering our
services out to Parish councils I do
know that in the cases the parish
councils that I visited when the MDC
Services were tendering they were not
they were not competitive
um and weren't employed by many parents
many parishes but um
anyway does that answer your question
counselor siddle counselor stamp yeah
thank you chair um just for uh Mr
Harwood White's benefit there's always
been issues with cemetery and glass
cutting I can remember going with Matt
Wilson and Richard Holmes to the Malden
with councilor what's her name Vanessa
Bell
Vanessa Bell to Burnham's surgery at
like cemetery and we were absolutely
disgusted and then we got the then it
was brought in about wild in and then
you got the problem with adders adders
bite they bite dogs they bite humors in
the cemetery so I understand that we've
had all these issues and I'm really
disappointed because I think we did look
at purchasing equipment to be able to
charge out our services to look at a
business opportunity which is what
cancer siddler and counselor Durham has
actually said I do think we're often so
inward looking at this Council we were
so we looked at it for truecam and we
never did anything about it and so
that's all I've been weedled down to
more or less hardly anything now
um but my point chairman that I want to
raise and the question I have is 3.6.1
the community housing Reserve to cover
the three-month contract extension for
an employment support coach can we have
an update on that because I do believe
that
um the position has been met by DWP can
somebody actually say that and now it's
actually yes some the likes have gone on
on the screen so I think okay it would
be really nice that members could
actually have an update on that and I
just like Clarity chair that it is I
just like Clarity that we are still
having to pay this 12 500 because the
deal lapsed is that quite clear yeah
that's fine it's like Miss weekly and
Tara for the um minutes councilor layers
arrived
there's always a bit of a delay in terms
of
when we received the funding from when
we put the bid in
um we've had an officer in the
employment coach role now for two years
and we have just secured additional
two-year funding through the DWP to keep
the employment coach on for a further
two years
um but there was just that Gap in in
time where the funding for the role ran
out and we needed to keep everyone on
the assumption that we would get that
further DWP funding
um so we have we did request a
supplementary estimate to cover that Gap
um and where we can we will look to
repay that through any understand within
the housing service if we have any by
the end of this financial year
thank you do you want to come back
counselors really quickly can I just ask
why there was the Gap and and I'm
grateful that you've turned around and
said you're going to try and Claw it
back but I just wondered why there was a
gap because I think we would have known
that the contract was due to end was it
our end or was it the DWP thanks
um I think it's just historical
um from where the books term contract
was originally due to end so when we
then were in the seat of further DWP
funding so we did have this historically
as well
um so it was just to ensure that we
didn't lose that resource in the time it
took to hear from the DWP that we did
have actually further finding for that
following two years
okay councilor Fluker how long was the
Gap chairman
between three three months
thank you
the only the comment I would make in
going back to cemeteries and grass
cutting because this is referring to
um quarter one which is April to June
well we all remember what June was like
it was so hot the grass wasn't growing
um and then hey Presto in July the
heavens opened and we were all cutting
you know I know because I look out my
bedroom window onto a golf course I know
exactly how much I've been cutting so
I'm a bit concerned about what quarter
two might bring
I don't know if you've got a comment
thank you chair
um we still have those salary savings so
we are still using those to fund
additional support when we need it but
it's certainly not long-term solution
chairman hence the service review okay
okay
right uh
members were being asked to note and
agree
yeah louder thank you thank you very
much indeed
okay
next item on the agendas oh no we've
done that one
okay
uh budgetary control how's that 30th of
June 2023 who's going to take us through
this and it is Miss Lucas oh no
he's got your name down on my list you
see Tara sent me a crib sheet but Mr
porteous
thank you chair
uh this is the report outlining the
budget monitoring position of the
council at the end of quarter one
it is for the committee to note
as that quarter of one we are
forecasting a 66 000 pound under spend
and it is detailed in different ways
within the report
in table one on page 21 it shows an
overspend against employees an
underachievement of income
and a significant up
understand against non-employee budgets
in table two page 22 the significant
non-employee budgets and forecasts are
broken down service by service
similarly in table 3 page 23 the
significant income budgets and forecasts
are broken down service by service also
the variances of each are explained
below each table in sections 4.3 and 4.4
but just to point out the largest
individual variants being forecast is an
underspend against household waste due
to reduced demand since the pandemic
ended
uh for example one this truck has now
been used
employee and members cost variances are
shown in table four on page 25
these are forecast to be very close to
budget
there is a potential pressure on the
vacancy Factor
due to agents see staff required in some
areas such as planning while new staff
are being recruited into the new Service
delivery structure
but this will be closely monitored
throughout the year
there was an adjustment for National
Insurance which has created Surplus
budget and is largely offsetting the
vacancy Factor variants
table five and paragraph 7.1 page 25
shows the impact of increased interest
rates which are higher than budgeted
so it should bring in an additional 250
000 pounds over the course of the
financial year
this will also be closely monitored due
to interest rates regularly changing
and table six on page 26 shows
collection rates are tracking slightly
above budgeted this year
and finally table seven shows the impact
on the general fund balance
with current budget variances factored
in
bringing the forecast general fund
balance is at the 31st of March 2024
up to nearly 5.4 million thank you chair
thank you very much on the Facebook good
news I just want to comment on the
report it's a very good report and it
it's very clear and each of the lines of
for members benefit are explained so
whoever put that together thank you very
much I'm going to go to councilor fluka
first thank you do you know I was just
about to say that because I think Mr
poultius I mean you and I have lived
through several one five one officers
and and some of whom aren't one five one
officers uh but I must admit
um I through you chairman but I'll look
at him I do like his reports and but
chairman is an excellent new story in
here uh and I look forward to the
officers confirming this later
um I think just for the benefit of the
record chairman and the tape this report
is uh dated the uh he's at the 30th of
June
um and I think Mr porteous mentioned
chairman that um we you know we still
had Contracting staff on board and
everything else and vacancies to fill
but I'm sure chairman all the members of
the uh the committee will be hardened
when I give them this advice and I've
just checked this on the Malden District
Council website chairman and
if you indulge me to quote quote the
more District Council website there says
there are currently no vacancies
available at Malden District Council
that's excellent news chairman and the
officers should be commended thank you
very much well okay that may or may not
be the case but yeah and well if that's
what it says on the website and we'll
we'll hope our website is up to date in
an area of concern that I always have in
these respects is council tax collection
rates because knowing the pressure that
is on
um they are good at the moment but of
course they are very
yeah this in in the current economic
climate and the cost of doing crisis
they don't need to change very much
before there's a significant financial
impact but um unless members we are
being
yeah councilor stamp
really because
because and luckily I I had last year's
accounts as well because I've been
trying to understand some of the things
there all I would say I think it's an
excellent report but I was looking back
I I like to know what we did last year
as well and rad I know you can't do um
supporters because it gives you more
work but I sometimes find it easier
because you cancel tax rates you know
what you've just said about the budget
in the forecast I think was it last year
we were below what we were budgeted to
be the year before if that makes sense
sometimes it just put context for me it
might just only be me chairman because I
can be a little bit strange but I like
the information in front of me but I
think it's also an excellent report and
I support the recommendation Council
thank you chair uh just a couple of
points on refuse and recycling three 4.3
item one uh driver salaries
I know in the past that we have
supported Sue is in terms of those
salaries and is that something that
we're still doing and uh on item number
nine the card processing fees so we're
saying that this is 17 000 more than
expected but are we getting more car
parking fees than we expected as well so
is that balanced out
right I'm gonna I'm looking to Mr
Harwood white if that oh you have that
information here well Jim I don't have
the car park information that yeah it
actually falls to sue green if she's
still on the call chairman yeah
Miss Mrs Green do you have you can you
help us with the car parking point
so yes they
are going back to the report the car
park
the car park income is actually
um overall
um tracking higher than we had
originally got in the budget
historically
um what the variation is at the moment
is the fact that we've had
um an additional I think it was 130 000
I think was at least 40 years that was
added into our projected income for car
parking as part of the future Council
project a few years ago
um so that's what's kind of currently
showing is is a sort of significant
variation is the fact that the car park
income action is not a significant
different to kind of pre-covered that's
if we are or we would have been on track
for the levels of income
but at the moment it is showing under
because we have got this extra 130 000
that's been added in
um to the student income but without any
policy and behind that to generate that
additional income so there's no sort of
assumption that we would have increased
the car park charges significantly
um so that that's why there is a
variation
well if our car parking
rates are pretty back to pre-covered
we're doing extremely well I was with
the leader of Epping today and their car
parking revenues 25 less than it was
before covered so councilor said yeah so
so what is the reason that our fees are
more that may I come yep that's Lucas
thanks cancer I think that particular
pressure is as the report says due to
the the number of people paying by cards
being higher than
um than previously so
um obviously we don't really take cash
anymore in our car Parks so the number
of car transactions is higher and that
particular element of the pressure is
due to the extra card fees due to the
increased volume of card payments but
the The Wider pressure or that service
report reporting is around the car
parking income more generally if that
makes sense so because we so the fact
that we have gone to card processing and
not uh the cash we didn't we haven't
anticipated that there would be this
extra charge is that what we're saying
um I think I think there's been an
element probably of that built in but I
think the
um maybe the volume is higher than
originally anticipated but we can look
to make a budget adjustment for that
going forward to reflect the actual
nature of the transactions that we're
now experiencing yeah okay can I just
ask a question yes I appreciate the fact
that there's card processing
uh charges
um and I'm I would expect there's also
charges from my permit or whoever we use
for our pay by phone is that right
which will certainly be greater than it
yeah it was previously
um I might defer to
um see if that's okay if I don't know if
you've got the detail on that
um certainly going forward the the
majority of any additional fees so for
example from my permit are actually
included within the transaction fee that
the customer would pay so that isn't the
cost that we would pick up
um going forward good okay
um all right I've got councilor Thompson
then fitic and then fluka
thank you chairman actually I'm I'm not
I'm not familiar with my permit what's
my furnace yes oh ring but bring over
all the time I was actually assuming
that since Ringo charged another 40 or
50p on top of the actual fee yeah but we
weren't charged any but I'd be
interested to hear the answer well we're
not if we we just heard we use my permit
and well the customer Bears the cost no
yeah
fine councilor fitter I was just going
to say in terms of the charges it might
be because the merchant acquirer rate
has changed in any way shape or form as
well
um
yeah thanks we can we can go away and
look at the exact nature of those costs
but yeah there are costs to the counts
when price in terms of dealing as you
say with the merchant supplier so
um I we can take that away and get the
exact detail on that but yeah there are
costs to the council
um as part of that Arrangement councilor
fluka finally I mean with the caveats
that I always struggle when I look at
local Authority accounts but it seems to
me as though uh the revenue from the car
parks for this period is 360
000 so been in my model NatWest did to
me the other day they would charge me
three thousand six hundred pound to
count that sum if I paid it into the
bank uh and of course we then have the
costs of going around the machines and
collecting it but tell me what my
concern really is if we take the figure
of 360
000 pounds
um and everybody paid by card
um you know 18 000 would be the
equivalent of five percent and I don't
think anybody pays five percent on card
handling so you know I take a lot of
comfort from what the 151 Officer says
that um they're going to go away and do
a little bit of work on this because I
think five percent to handle cards is is
uh not the norm thank you chairman I
think that would be useful if we can get
the car uh card rate reported back for
the next meeting it would be because it
is a significant cost I'm going to go to
councilor Stanton and then councilor lay
mine's a quick one chair um do we get
charged a cup a car park do we get
charged a fee for debit cards for car
parking
we do as well do we do we know what that
that amount is to is it the same cancer
siddle
well no it's an interesting point or do
we are we going to wait to have the
information coming yeah I will I will
clarify because I don't want to
speculate but my my understanding is
that it's all cards it doesn't matter
whether it's a debit or credit card that
we would
um
okay well as I say I'll I will take that
away and get a definite answer we will
get an answer on all of our costs for
collecting car parking Revenue if
members are happy with that gasoline
thank you chair uh just a quick question
it are we able to build in I presume the
card charges are from the banks directly
or the financial institutions are we
able to build in the Tariff that
actually decreases with more use there's
normally a volume based charge would
save the council a lot more money the
more people we got into the actually
into the car Parks there's no physical
invite um involvement in the actual
Payment Processing so if you put
increase your volume it's not actual
cost to the bank in fact it's we could
look at savings that way by building in
that factor into our charging
sorry I haven't worked in the industry
yeah understand how it works it might be
an easy way to to do that Banks don't
tend to adjust charges where they don't
need to or not pointed out
again through your channel I will go
away and clarify but as you say my
experience of those kinds of contracts
and I haven't been involved in this
specific one at this council is as you
say there is a set of tariffs which is
based on volume and if you reach certain
thresholds in those those tariffs
reduced so it's it's based on that kind
of model yeah
I think it's it was a fair fair point
because
apart from council tax
car parking income is our biggest source
of income and the costs associated with
it you know are quite critical so the
low we can get those the better so we
will come back to that so
members we are just being asked to
note
thank you very much indeed and that
brings us
to the last item
tonight which is the fees and charges
policy before we start
we are not debating the individual fees
and charges we are debating the policy
so we're not going to start getting
involved in cost of warfage and cost of
this and that this is all about the
policy so um
uh who is uh oh that one is me okay yes
yeah same asleep this year
thank you thank you chair
um yeah so as you say uh this the
purpose of this report is to review the
fees and charges policies that have been
put forward by offices prior to
um the approval of the 24 25 budget and
the updated mtfs
um a further detailed schedule of fees
and charges and will be brought back
before this committee
um at a future meeting for their
approval so this is just to seek
um approval as to say of the policies
and the way in which those individual
fees and charges will be set
uh paragraph 3.3 summarizes
um the proposed changes to the policy
and appendix one sets out those policies
um line by line with any changes
highlighted um within that appendix
um in the majority of cases um we've
just simply clarified the council's
existing policy which is to charge a
minimum of uh full cost recovery
um and there's a couple of areas within
car parking where there are um specific
policy changes that are proposed um and
they're at the top of that table 3.3
um so I think that's probably all I
would say unless anyone's got any
questions thank you yeah I mean that's a
general rule we should have an absolute
minimum of uh cost of full recovery but
of course there are some items where
it's not lawful to charge more than cost
recovery unfortunately so we will go to
councilor Thompson first and cancel the
stamp
stamp was quicker with her hands I saw
you first cancel Steve Thompson thank
you very much
um absolutely agree with you chairman we
shouldn't be doing anything for less
than the actual cost
but I do have a couple of queries um one
is bulky waste collection I would hate
to see much more than a nominal fee
added to that simply because the
alternative is more fly tipping
green waste and replacement of bins I'm
afraid it isn't
it isn't the residents who break the
bins
it's the workers who break the bins and
I've been around this Loop a couple of
times already with with various
residents in my ward who've had the been
sort of flung back across the drive the
lids come off or whatever and then
they're asked to pay for a new one and
I'm sorry that's outrageous we we should
be claiming it but we should be claiming
it from sewers no or whoever's doing the
collection are you talking about the
screen wasted green waste or the food
waste yeah food any any of any of that
green beans black beans any of it we
should be if if the cruise or the crew
member is
causing the breakage then that company
whoever it is should be paying thank you
not the residents it's just not fair
enough well made some and they've broken
the lid off mine I must admit so um is
anybody's gotta
know okay right
um councilor stamp mine's just a quick
question really what when it says
Service delivery inquiry is
non-statutary can have an example of a
non-statutory inquiry and how how that
would be charged
thank you Council stamp I did actually
just pick up on that one before the
meeting because I wasn't sure myself
um so I think it's a fair question um I
don't know that we have got an answer on
that one yet so again I might have to
take that away unless any of my
colleagues on the call I've married
managed to clarify that line but yeah I
did ask the same question
yeah um sorry
it's green
chairman and
police are not General customer
qualities they are specific to land
charges
yeah thanks thanks chairman um just as
far as policy is concerned chairman it
was the policy of this Council to
increase warfage by inflation
particularly the Thames barges and
Kinder 151 officer confirmed that that's
actually been implemented for my suspect
the first of April and my my other
question is German and it goes back to
what we were considering earlier and
that is determined that
um the the uh I'll get to it in a moment
the the
um
Town and Country planning Act
uh allows for councils to charge a
monitoring fee which is quite modest for
in relation to section 106 agreements
um however chairman and I'm sure if this
was aware that was amended quite
significantly in 2019 and
um I draw officers attention to some of
our neighbors chairman for example
Braintree and Colchester and there are
others throughout the UK that charge
significant amounts of money to monitor
section 106 projects now I've heard the
argument that we never wrote this into
local development plan chairman but it
is a statute and I suspect statue is
actually Sovereign to our local
development plan chairman and and I'd
also say chairman that under section
106a of the Town and Country planning
act you're not looking for a pupily uh
no
um you we can we can
renegotiate uh planning obligations
anyway but I think chairman bear in mind
when you look at other council's fees
and charges and they make this quite
clear and and these are not County
councils these are councils you know
district councils and City councils and
they've got fees in there fixed fees for
1500 quid you know to monitor things I'm
not saying it would cover the costs that
we've spoken to tonight but it certainly
would close the budget so chairman um
I'd ask that officers go away and
consider that thank you because I think
it I think it would sit right and proper
in our policies think
I would hope we would be benchmarking
Services uh fees and charges but and in
order to make the maximum amount that we
can legally make Miss Lucas
um just with regard to the question
about section 106 and the second to last
um line of the appendix one does set out
that yeah we do seek to charge a
monitoring fee based on individual
section 106 cases so that that is no
change to our existing policies um
well could we just to speed things up
could we have a breakdown then please of
what you've collected through that
because my understanding is it's not 0.5
uh a value and and that's the very
that's that's the way of doing things I
understand before 2019 but I wouldn't
expect you to know the answer so I'm
sure all members will enjoy receiving
that later thank you and perhaps we can
Benchmark against our neighbors
Council the driver
thank you chair my my question relates
actually to clinical waste uh which
actually is referred to further down in
the report
um pre the transformation it might have
been pre-covered I'm not quite sure
which
we decided as a council to stop
collecting clinical waste
the consequence of that is that there
are now thousands of people across
Malden District who have to organize
individual collections for for clinical
waste from their homes
so we are we have a system where people
are running around the district
collecting from Individual houses
clinical waste whereas previously
you brought it to the council Offices
here
he sat in a box somebody came along once
a week or whatever collected it all once
and that was it so we have introduced
what can only be a very cumbersome
expensive system where I would have
thought we could have very easily found
a solution now particularly as we are
opening this building up more and
potentially there might be other
locations where clinical waste could be
left and collected from a few locations
rather than thousands of locations
across the district thank you now I do
recall when that ceased because we would
quite often come in and see the yellow
bins on the
um Mrs Green can you remember the
reasons for c-sync
that um
and services
that this was a more cost effective way
and that she provided a service for the
residents but I'm sure my colleague and
Hannah who's I think I want to call I
think we can give an undertaking that we
can go back and review those costs
because obviously if there is a more
efficient way to live in that service of
course that's what we want to do
I think that's a policy that could be
reviewed yeah from a resident's point of
view it is certainly not helpful and I
find it hard to believe that going
around thousands of houses picking up
individual Yellow Boxes is more
efficient more cost effective than going
to one location where residents bring
the box to that location thank you okay
well we we will we will
look at that cancer with an aging
population we do have an increasing
number of clinical waste needs councilor
fluka another box and chairman I just
want to be I asked a question about
warfage and the policy account so I'm
not sure if anybody came back on that
but I'll happily take an answer uh
afterwards I would rather you would
because we did so we weren't talking
about individuals
I made it absolutely clear it was the
policy a council that was agreed that
they would go up by inflation I just
wanted to make sure that that's the case
if that was agreed I'm sure it is but we
will we will wait for the answer
so members
um
we need this do you approve the policies
as set out in point two councilors
oh it is a recommendation to council so
we'll need a yes counselor um sorry well
I I can't support the recommendations as
is on on account of the the damage to
the bins I know it's a small item but I
don't want to agree that residents
should pay to for damage to bins that
they didn't cause so if we could have an
amendment for if you'd allow me to add
an amendment to that effect or
or or if you would or whatever but I I'm
afraid I would have to sit on my hands
for this because I don't think residents
should be paying for damage they don't
cause I just thought I'm just gonna wait
hold on councilor fluka I mean can't Mrs
Green when somebody reports a bin broken
are the circumstances of that damage
taken into account
my understanding is that they would be
chairman so if there was evidence that
that was caused and by serious then
certainly we wouldn't be looking to
charge that is my understanding but
again happy to take that away and this
um this is where you can comment any
further
they've been stolen so it's just making
sure that we are making a full cost
recovery for those replacement bins when
they've been stolen but where there is
damage then yes we will consider that
damage and seen us associated with
replacing those bins
yeah I don't know whether you heard that
so if if somebody has it stolen they
have to pay
but if it's broken they don't is that
basically what we're saying
yes of what I'm saying is that
and they would then pay for a
replacement where the bin has been
damaged and we can see that it's been
damaged by the crews then we would like
could obviously making sure that that
cost isn't incurred by the resident but
that is that with on a case-by-case
basis
has anybody prove anything still okay
well the onus of proof is on the
resident
it's only the it's only the the food
caddies Council of fluke yeah and I
propose that that we we know cancer
Thompson's comments and and we agreed it
agreed a recommendation and and then we
can all debate
uh the theft of bins and the
apportionment of blame when we get to
full Council
Chancellor fuka I'm I'm inclined to to
agree in that we don't want to be
working all sorts of complications into
this because it is just a policy
um and as we said it is cost recovery
and it's pretty easy for somebody to say
oh my Bin's been nicked and they're
using it for something else in their
Garden
um growing potatoes or something in
their green bin but um
so members please as it's a
recommendation Council just please show
by a show of hands if you are agreement
councilor flukery
I just this is a recommendation to
council are you agreeing
no questions
okay well that's absolutely I'm
brilliant majority anyway so that's it
thank you very much indeed
well if you if you really we I think we
know where you're coming from councilor
stamp and it was good it is going to go
to full Council so it is agreed thank
you very much indeed uh final item um
items of Virgin business
uh there are none you'll be glad to hear
we don't need an exclusion of public and
press so we close this meeting that's
dead on nine o'clock
thank you
not meant to me counselor